you probably wouldn't trust a robot to
babysit your kids or write you a
prescription or even cut your hair so
why should you trust one to manage your
money robo advisors have been steadily
gaining popularity since their
introduction in 2008 with total client
assets now exceeding one trillion
dollars and expected to be 2.9 trillion
by 2025. that's a lot of money to put
under the care of a bunch of machines
let's hope they don't become self-aware
and use it to finance the great robot
uprising despite the name there are no
actual robots involved the term robo
advisor refers to algorithms that
automatically manage an investment
portfolio based on your financial
situation and goals these are tools that
financial experts have had access to for
decades but are now available to anyone
there are dozens to choose from like
betterment and wealthfront and most
traditional brokerages are now offering
their own versions but should you use
one and how can you know which one is
right for you
[Music]
much like a human financial advisor a
robo advisor will begin by asking you a
bunch of questions about yourself
how much do you make a year how much do
you have saved how much are you willing
to invest what are you saving for
retirement house your kids college how
much risk can you handle it uses that
information to build an investment
portfolio mathematically engineered to
meet your goals and continually updates
it as the market changes
one of the biggest advantages of robo
advisors is their low barrier of entry
most human advisors charge an annual fee
of around one to two percent of your
total account balance and require a
minimum investment in the hundreds of
thousands of dollars
robo advisors on the other hand
typically charge less than half of that
and most have extremely low to no
balance requirements
how can they afford to do that by
automating tasks that are difficult and
time consuming for humans to do
two of the major ones are rebalancing
and tax loss harvesting in finance
rebalancing refers to the buying and
selling of assets to maintain a certain
level of allocation or risk let's say
you and your financial advisor decide
that your optimal investment strategy is
to have thirty percent in emerging
markets thirty percent in traditional
blue chips and forty percent in
government bonds if your emerging market
stocks rally it will throw off this
balance and your advisor will sell some
off and reinvest it in other categories
to get you back to your desired ratio
of course selling stocks at a profit
incurs a capital gains tax and that's
where tax loss harvesting comes in by
strategically selling other stocks at a
loss your advisor can offset the gains
and minimize your tax bill because the
practice can be abused the irs has very
strict rules about how and when it can
be done
rebalancing and tax loss harvesting are
both powerful tools for getting the most
out of your portfolio they're also
a big pain in the butt which is why many
human advisors will only do them for you
once a year the robo advisors can do
them every day finding opportunities and
strategies that no human eye could see
the downside of this automation is that
you have little to no control over which
stocks you own robo advisors are solidly
based on modern portfolio theory which
states that the best strategy for most
investors is to diversify their
portfolio to just match the market but
if you're the kind of investor who wants
to try to beat the market by picking
individual stocks then a robo advisor
won't be enough for you instead you
might use a trading app like robinhood
which lets you buy individual stocks
while avoiding the usual fees and
minimums
but be warned while a few have made
fortunes this way like warren buffett
the vast majority of such investors
underperform the market another reason
you may not want to rely on a robo
advisor is if you have very specific or
complex financial needs like estate
planning or an unusual tax situation
though they've become much more
sophisticated over the last decade
they're still designed to fulfill pretty
basic investment functions
some people also want the human touch
that comes with a flesh and blood
advisor money is after all a highly
emotional topic advisors do more than
crunch numbers they listen they educate
they help you understand what your goals
really are and how much risk you're
really willing to tolerate a
robo-advisor won't be there to talk you
off the ledge when the market is having
a bad day
still for those who are just entering
the world of investing robo advisors are
a sound and cost-effective tool that has
opened the door to millions of people
who are essentially excluded by high
fees and balance minimums if you're
thinking about using one it's pretty
easy to compare rates and services
online make sure they offer rebalancing
and tax loss harvesting at no additional
cost if you want your portfolio to
reflect your values you can find some
that allow you to prioritize socially
responsible investments and if you still
crave the personal touch many online
brokerages now supplement your
robo-advisor with a human advisor for
much less than they would traditionally
cost
but remember that technology is
constantly evolving robo advisors can
spare you from having to watch your
portfolio every day but you should still
know how they work and what changes are
on the horizon advancements in ai are
expanding what areas of financial
planning can be automated and you should
research any new services before diving
in that said so far they've been doing a
pretty good job with basic investments
so if that's your need you can feel
safer with a robot handling your
portfolio and a pair of scissors
and that's our two cents
before you go could a blind gamer beat
you in mortal kombat have you ever heard
of the gay rodeo and why are these guys
putting underwear on goats
subcultured a brand new documentary
series from pbs answers those questions
and so many more exploring lesser-known
communities and folks that have had a
major impact on the mainstream check it
out over on pbs voices link in our
description and let them know that two
cents sent you
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
patron
[Music]
you